peu
[Musique]
paris re devenu pour trois mois la
capitale diplomatique de monde au palais
de chaillot met à la disposition de
l'organisation des nations unies les
délégués des 58 nations participantes
ont fait leur entrée
je me suis vincent auriol président de
la république et lui a apporté à leur
arrivée le salut de la france
il vous appartient que la paix ne soit
pas nous permet aussi décisif à la porte
a jusqu'au sommet vous ne se lit pas
seulement mesdames messieurs justifié
par l'histoire
vous n'allez pas seulement en conscience
d'avoir rempli un devoir sacré vous le
savez pas sur quoi la bénédiction joie
deux des mères et de fanfare du mans
[Musique]
semblait a procédé à l'élection de son
nouveau président s'affronter une voix
contre 20 monsieur ivan et les culs de
l'australie a été appelé à présider la
troisième session de l'onu
le monde a les yeux fixés sur paris
l'appel à préfet boudera c'est un leader
[Musique]